hi ben uh i'm a freshman at ub um
from uh dutchess county uh you talked
about divorce rates and how divorce
rates have been increasing this country
country since the 1970s and just kind of
alluded to that as evidence of the
failure
of radically sort of leveled off since
like the the 2000s like the early 2000s
but yes they're still higher than they
were in the 50s and 40s right
couldn't that also simply because of the
fact that women are now more
socioeconomically
able to be independent than men like how
can you say that
radical feminism caused divorces and
also ignored the fact that possibly it
was just that women became
able to be independent therefore they
started to divorce more because
they would be becoming economic and
economically independent
in the same period as they were getting
divorced as they were getting married
meaning that these aren't 20-year
marriages that are breaking up these are
like five-year marriages that are
breaking up which suggests to me
a mental shift that's taken place in the
nature of how we think about marriage
rather than socioeconomic status being
the indicator meaning that
i suppose that economics could tie into
this except for the fact that people who
are higher income tend to stay married
more often than people who are lower
income
right so that sort of undercuts the
argument a little bit meaning that if
you're if you're richer you tend to be
married longer on average people who are
poor tend to get divorced where did you
get that uh statistical census bureau
you